keita left camp three days ago on a
journey into the jungle the three days
of his journey can be described by
displacement distance and the direction
distance and direction vectors or
displacement vectors and displacement is
distance with the direction and the
vectors are d1 d2 and d3 and they list
them right over here the distances are
given in kilometers how far is kiera
from camp at the end of day three
so let's just think about what's
happening on day one let's say this is
his starting point his displacement he
starts here and he goes there but if you
break it down based on i guess if you
call this direction the hor if you call
this direction actually draw a compass
here if you say that this is north
this is east
this is west and that this is south you
can break it down by how much he went in
the east direction and how much he went
in the north direction so this is saying
he went seven in the east direction
one two three four five six seven seven
in the east direction and he went eight
in the north direction one two three
four five six seven eight
just like that this is seven and this is
eight and then on day two he went six in
the east in the
six six units i guess these are
kilometers six kilometers to the east
one two three four five six and he went
two by two kilometers to the north one
two so he ends up
right over here six and two and then
finally day three the component of his
displacement that is to the east
is two and the component of his
displacement that's to the north is 9
is 9. and so to figure out how far he is
at from camp at the end of day 3 we just
have to figure out what is his total
displacement what is the length of the
vector that's the sum of all of these so
what is the length of
this vector right over here and we could
call this let's call this d sub t for
total displacement total total
displacement
and you can see how this is arranged
that our total displacement vector is
just going to be the sum of
d1
let me do those in the appropriate
colors it's just going to be the sum of
d1
d2
and d3
and if you're summing these vectors you
can just add the corresponding
components so for example d
the total displacement is going to be
equal to
the sum of the horizontal or not i
should say the east the displacements in
the east direction so it's going to be
seven
plus six
plus
two
plus two and then in the north direction
you have eight
plus six or sorry eight plus two
plus nine
plus nine and so our total displacement
vector if we were to write it in this
form
is going to be this is 13 plus two it's
going to be 15 in the to the east or the
the component of displacement in the
eastern direction is 15 and then the
northern direction is 10 plus 9 19.
so that's this vector right over here
it's 15
it's comple it's component to the in the
east is 15 and to the north is 19
is 19. so let me make that clear so this
this distance right over here or this
if i were to make this a triangle the
length of this side of the triangle here
is 19 and that's the total his total
displacement in the northern direction
and his total displacement in the
his total displacement in the eastern
direction
is that 15.
is that 15. so what's going to be the
length of our displacement vector or
what's the magnitude of our displacement
vector the magnitude of our total
displacement
is well it's pythagorean theorem this is
a right triangle 15 squared plus 19
squared is going to be the magnitude
squared or we could say that the
magnitude is equal to the square root of
15 squared
plus 19 squared
plus 19 squared so let me get my
calculator out
all right so i have the square root of
15 squared
plus 19 squared
gives 24 let's see they want us to round
to the nearest tenth 24.2
so 24.2 kilometers and they say what
direction is keita from camp at the end
of day three round to the nearest degree
your answer should be between zero and
180 degrees
so distance i'm assuming this would just
be the convention they should be a
little bit more precise here in their
wording or a little bit less ambiguous
is the convention is the angle relative
to if we're thinking of the coordinate
axes the positive x-axis on this it
would be you could say the eastern
direction so it's really this angle
right over here let's call that theta
and how could we figure out what theta
is we it's part of this right triangle
we know this side has length 19 we know
this side has 15. so we know the
opposite side theta and we know the
adjacent side to theta so what what what
trig function involves opposite and
adjacent well tangent involves opposite
opposite and adjacent so we could write
that the tangent of theta
tangent of theta is equal to 19 over 15
is equal to opposite over adjacent 19
over 15.
and to solve for theta we can just say
and we got to make sure that our angle
if we just take the inverse tangent here
is going is actually the angle we're
looking for but inverse tangent the
convention is it'll give you an angle
that is between negative
pi over 2 and pi if you're thinking in
radians but since we're thinking degrees
it'll give you an angle between negative
90 degrees and 90 degrees and this angle
is clearly in that it's it's actually
between 0 and 90 degrees so when we take
inverse tangent we know that we're going
to get the right angle otherwise we
would have to make some adjustments so
theta is going to be equal to the
inverse tangent of 19 over 15
of 19
over 15
which is equal to let's get our
calculator out let's make sure that we
are in yep we are in degree mode
and so let's take the inverse tangent
of
divided by
15 which is equal to let's see they want
us to round to the nearest degree so
52 degrees if we round to the nearest
degree
52 degrees which also looks right right
over here this looks like it looks like
a little bit more than a 45 degree angle
which 52 degrees seems to fit the bill
and we are done